we had so many wonderful times he was
certainly a mentor as a kid for me we're
gonna miss him dearly and but it was
just a very special person who just
found a way to help everyone of us
around he never lost his heritage and I
think he taught me that more than
anything else in life that Canada was
important and that to be Canadian
something special a proud Canadian first
and foremost it's no surprise Ellen was
a big supporter of hockey and the NHL
when I got traded to LA you should come
and stay at my house we stayed at his
house and Robin and Brendan at that time
were like 14 and 12 I think running
around playing basketball in the
backyard and I knew I was getting traded
and got the call and went to Edmonton
came back spent another week with him
but you know more importantly he was
such a big huge hockey fan so for these
alumni taking the ice is a fitting
tribute for the actor it was awesome
when I heard that you know we're on a
man tonight big-time support of the
Kings but big-time support of the NHL I
mean he always came to the NHL Awards
the morning on Toronto so he was always
there to help he's just one of those
guys that you know everybody has a story
about him and how great he was and you
know he'll be missed and we are closer
with his family